يعني تصريحات بن كفير احمد وخصوصا تلك
التي قال انه لا يمكن مناقشه او ليس من
مقبول مناقشه سياسه اليوم التالي في مجلس
فيه بيني جانس يعني ماذا ماذا كان يعني
هذا هل يعني هذا ان هناك خلافا داخل مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي
الان محمود اذا اخذنا منذ بدايه تشكيل
مجلس الحرب هذا كان كان هناك معارضه من
قبل بنفير و سموتريتش وجناح هما لتشكيل
هذه الحرب لانه لانه يسحب البساط من
تحتهما في التاثير على القرارات وعلى صنع
القرار الاسرائيلي والان ياتي هذا الامر
او هذا الاحتجاج والتهديد بالانسحاب من
الائتلاف الحكومي والذي ادى في النهايه
الى تغيير راي رئيس الوزراء بنيمين
نتنياهو وعدوله عن موافقته المبدئيه على
مناقشه هذا البند في مجلس الحرب وشط به من
اجنده الاجتماع بمعنى ان رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو اصبح الان اسيرا لطلبات
ورغبات
وتهديدات كل من بنفير وس موتتش والخلاف
بينهما وبين اجنحه مجلس الحرب من خارج
الائتلاف الحكومي الذين يعتبرونهم بانهم
انتهزوا فرصه السابع من اكتوبر ليكونوا
شركاء في صنع القرار وانه يجب ان يك ان
تكون مساله الحرب من اختصاص المجلس مجلس
ال الوزاري المصغر اي المعني بالامن
وب بالامن و و بالسياسه الخارجيه هذا ما
دفع به كل من بنفير و سموتريش لدفع
نتنياهو نحو الرضوخ الى مطالبهم والرضوخ
الى جمهورهم الذي يحتاجه
نتنياهو في خصوصا في اليوم التالي بعد
الحرب لانه يعرف بان بيلي جانس وجناحه سلن
يكون جزءا من مجلس الحرب في حين تم
الانتهاء منها او تم الوصول الى وقت دائم
لاطلاق النار وسيعود نتنياهو ليكون جزءا
من ائتلافه الحاكم الذي يعتمد فيه على
جناحي بنفير وسموت ليستمر في هذا الحكم
وبدونهما ان قرارهما الانسحاب من هذا
الائتلاف فانه سيسقط بنيامين نتنياهو
خصوصا في ظل استطلاعات الراي اخرها اجرتها
القناه الثان عش الاسرائيليه والتي اظهر
تراجع شعبيه الائتلاف الحكومي اي ائتلاف
بمين نتنياهو واحزاب اليمين المتطرف بالى
الى الى النصف وتراجع حزب الليكود بشكل
كبير
وعلو تاييد جناح بيلي جانس الذي اعتبره من
استطلعت ارائهم من الاسرائيليين ب 52%
اعتبروه انه هو الرجل المؤهل لقياده
اسرائيل بعد الحرب ونتنياهو نال على تاييد
31% ما يعني ان الاتجاهات السياسيه في
الشارع الاسرائيلي تذهب الى الاستغناء عن
الائتلاف الحكومي بقياده نتنياهو وتبديله
بمعارضيه مثل بلي جانس وهذا يستوعبه
نتنياهو جيدا لذا فهو لا يريد ان تحدث اي
تغييرات او انتخابات مبكره او تغيير سياسي
بسقوط الحكومه في اليوم التالي فيخضع بذلك
الى رغبات بنفير وسموت